wir laufen um ein ganzes aus regen mit
astrid ley
hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal
wandern bekam zu einem etwas anderem
video und zwar hat mich gefragt ob ich
nicht lust hätte zusammen mit hanna sony
und apple rim das erweiterungs pack vier
jahreszeiten für sims 4 auszuprobieren
und ihr erkennt es schon ich habe den
sommer bekommen
das erweiterungs pack ist nämlich ab
sofort erhältlich und dann würde ich
sagen spielen wir das mal mehr
ach so ganz wichtig ich habe natürlich
auch eine limo am start und ein alpen
früchte teller kann abweichen in meinem
opa sein
ich möchte das spiel nämlich nicht nur
spielen sondern versuchen meinem sind
richtig gut kochen beizubringen und am
ende die beste party aller zeitlichen
schmeißen mit im westen essen aller
zeiten ich hab das spiel nämlich
letztens wieder angespielt für diese
kooperation und mir ist wieder
eingefallen wie lustig die in der küche
stehen und wie sie kochen also lasst uns
nicht lang schnacken und spielen geil
hier sieht man schon die vier
jahreszeiten frühling sommer herbst und
winter
das ist unser erweiterungs pack vier
jahreszeiten im gesetz da gibt es ja
noch meinen katzen rochat leben zeit für
freunde an die arbeit nun lieber nicht
so play das ist mein allererstes let's
play fm ich schon so ein bisschen wie
haben das ständig ganz so cool so ich
heiße maroni
ich bin ein junger ackermann ich merke
jetzt schon ich werde mich viel zu lange
mit der gestaltung meiner person
auseinander setzen
ich lauf schon so persönlichkeit ist
nicht so wichtig kümmern wir uns erst
ums aussehen
ich bin relativ hell aber im sommer bin
ich auch ein bisschen gebräunter immer
ich habe große augen
das sind meine augen ja das schon ich
habe so eine knubbel stupsnase so eine
mischung aus glücklichen stück sich so
ich habe gerade blond aber wir haben nur
eine harte aber nicht mehr nimmt das
make-up ich trage mega viel make-up
izmir letzter ist aufgefallen
gesichtsbemalung jammern es ist sommer
ich brauche
ich muss den hut ausziehen der sie zu
warm es wird spannend vor einer portion
nach meiner operation meiner position
nein ich habe nichts machen lassen
klamotten perfekt schuhe passen außer
dieses face machen wir das jetzt weg
raus mit den accessoires
ach das ist ja hier mit der erweiterung
na gut dann ganz siemens blumen für
welches wetter soll das denn sein
ganz cool aus ich mein ich würde es nie
so anziehen aber der ist schön das ist
auch schön wenn ich so eine party
schmeißt dann muss ich natürlich auch so
was schickes anhaben ich bin noch ein
bisschen ehrlicher auf jeden fall kann
der hintern schön dick sein bisschen
mehr bauch ich hab das wichtigste
vergessen tattoos man kann noch tattoos
machen was ich ganz geil aus und das
tattoo sind cool aus guten tag ich habe
ich habe sämtlichen anlagen
jetzt bin ich das wirklich nur das
sixpack aber das lassen wir mal wieder
zu 15.000 da wir ja die beste köchin in
der nachbarschaft werden wollen brauchen
wir auf jeden fall essen ich werde
meisterköchen genießerin gesellig war
ehrgeizig wir machen nämlich die beste
party aller zeiten jetzt kommen wir zum
wichtigsten teil welche jahreszeit
nehmen wir natürlich den sommer wenn ihr
die anderen jahreszeiten sehen wollt die
gibt es dann bei hanna sony und fannie
mae grimm 20.000 stadtbudget haben wir
wie immer hier
willow creek springs oder newcrest
willow creek
das ist ein tolles einsteiger haus in
locri du kannst auf dieses grundstück
hätten um einzuziehen
wer kein biegungen uns die berghain
biegung ich dachte haben den sommer
warum ist sie schlecht drauf warum bist
du nur überraschen wir spielen doch grad
erst was ist noch okay wir haben es ja
sommer tag eins von sieben ja gewitter
perfekter tag zum haus bauen wir wollen
eine pool party schmeißt also braucht
ein haus und alles drum herum was dazu
passt
[Musik]
das ist unser pool
wir brauchen jetzt eine küche ich muss
die beste köchin aller zeiten werden ich
brauche viel platz leute das was
youtuber nicht kennen umgehen okay wir
wollen meisterköchen werden das heißt
wir brauchen alles was in der weiblichen
braucht eine mikrowelle oh mein gott ich
muss auch wenn so viel geld auszugeben
außenaktivitäten wasser belang einmal
richtig cool boom so ich habe kein geld
fürs klo ich habe nur noch 66 online ich
muss irgendwas verkaufen aber nicht
meine außenrat er gut shady muss weg
jetzt können wir uns ein klo leisten
waschbecken kloten dusche nicht genug
geld für eine dumme leute sie hat doch
schon was nichts außer dem fedpol
jetzt können wir spielen ja ich ja schon
wie es regnet ok hygiene du willst
gewaschen werden das klingt falsch ist
ich habe keinen dach gebaut
sie wird vom blitz getroffen
du wirst vom blitz getroffen ich war zum
nächsten und schaut euch diesen punkt es
tut mir so leid bei natürlichen dach
fenster werden natürlich auch gut
sag ich mal so ne was merkt man dass ich
nicht oft sims spiele waren
[Musik]
endlich zurück mit dach und fenstern gbt
duschen jetzt bitte duschen das ist ja
cool mit dem gewitter
das ist vielmehr dazu kann man gut
schlafen kochen ja wir müssen erstmal
üben zu kochen denn wir haben ein planen
die beste party aller zeiten ist immer
noch passiert mir ausständig wow
wenn ich hier lese tus machen das nicht
essen bitte geh nicht nein will ist das
dein ernst wo hast du dich jetzt einfach
ja das bin ich
scheiß drauf das ist ab und setz dich
bitte hierhin uns draußen gewittert ist
man sein käse drin freunde für eine
pool-party freunde für die poolparty
astrid nach bei der rein bitten
dabei hätten sie allein mit lustig
vorstellen meine freunde setzten alle
muss mit allen beste freunde werden sie
müssen alle zu einer grillparty kommen
lässt sich selbst vor dem spiegel zu
helfen versuchen
du hast kein spiegel was ist los mit dir
angst vor es tut mir leid vanessa warum
guckst du die anderen so böse an
das sind unsere neuen freunde jetzt
hänge nicht am handy das ist total
unhöflich ist eine bilder fenster
kommunal vanessa hat anscheinend so was
von das bedürfnis sich in einem spiel
anzuschauen kenne ich nur zu gut wie
beruhigen wir uns im gewitter
du bist stark verschärft also jetzt ist
sonntags gewitter ab morgen wird es warm
und dann wird es richtig heiß feiertag
erntedankfest und sommer gibt's kein
feiertag wir haben keine feiertage das
heißt wir müssen uns eigenen pool party
schmeißt wird unser feiertag sein feiere
einfach mein geburtstag ist wirklich im
sommer geburtstag neue traditionen
wählen plan spaß party stimmung
was macht man doch in meiner trinken
essen auf jeden fall gibt es ja auch
essen festtagsessen savegames qualität
was ist mit dir los solchen job so ach
ja ich rede mit dir
such dir einen job hat nochmal wir
brauchen einen job vanessa jetzt erst
mal einen job als köchin
wir müssen können wären da sein gefunden
soll ich das mal nachkochen sind uns
wieso früchtebrot nicht teil der sich
keine gegen city machen oder was danke
erreicht was ist das das ist wunderschön
warum ist es da so jetzt habe ich einen
job keinen spaß
ja so ist das meine liebe das macht doch
spaß jacobi sie sich freut dass auf die
plätze auf was ist das hier mein gott an
island city flitzer der [ __ ] zu
klatschen
[Musik]
die fische kommen muss ihn rein
oh mein gott so tag eins vorbei die welt
geht unter der test besser besser wird
besser mit wir sind waren hungrig das
ist gut wenn es sei denn wir müssen
kochen schönherr würzen
den speck ist jetzt einfach ignoriert
aber das ist okay ein bisschen sollst du
dich jetzt schon wieder anpeilen
warum kann ich das beanspruchen reisen
alleine reisen
dann reisen wir mal in die bibliothek
kannst du dich mal bitte umziehen kochen
schwingen den löffel so nenne ich mein
erstes kochbuch du musst besser während
der besser wäre besser besser wird
besser mit besser wäre es aber besser
wissen schon bei der arbeit seien
schnell nach hause
mel hat level 2 fähigkeit kochen sehr
gut 16 minuten bis zur arbeit ja jetzt
ist meine arbeit und meine freunde meine
freunde meine freunde neue freunde neue
freunde haben heute viel zeit wir reisen
denn die stadt und suchen uns darauf
neue freunde
wir brauchen viele freunde für unsere
pool party mit allen jetzt auch so schön
viel reisen jetzt mit seinen freunden
alle kommen mit dir ok wo geht's dann
gibt's hier irgendwas sommerliches
beginnen park dahin bitte lasst uns
rollschuhfahren im park das macht jedem
spaß wenn ich jetzt friends mit den
leuten oder nicht ich bin auf sims
sozialer als im echten leben und meine
freunde meine freunde meine neue
freundin neue freunde kommt gar zu
lassen zwar bis auf toilette quatschen
schon abend aber doch heute gar nicht
kochen gelernt ich musste die bibliothek
aber ich habe schon tags freunde sind
die bedürftig muss alleine leute sorry
gerne kochen so level 3 jetzt machen wir
uns level 3 abendessen buntbarsch aus
der pfanne gebraten und schon hast so
viel schon gemüse und da das und herum
er klar gerne tue lassen aber vergesst
dich nicht umzuziehen fürs essen er kann
ja nur im bikini essen ist ein uhr
nachts nicht schlafen essen schlafen
schlafen kopshoff schiffs trage jetzt
mach bitte auf es wird langweilig du
musst immer bei mir schmeckt's machen
ok unsere
ich kann schon gut kochen und kleine du
musst immer bei mir schmeckt's machen
heute hat mal war eine geburtstag
festmahl kochen kam vorbei ich muss
leider gar nicht einladen ich bin schon
level film kochen
ich kann für meine festmahl nur level 1
sachen kochen
geburtstag
was machst du da war ich muss wirklich
viel wie schmeckt zwar war das
nachkochen gesellschaftliches ereignis
plan dass wir die einladung gewesen war
kurz ich muss mein gesellschaftliches
ereignis krank und nein das ist eine
geburtstagsparty
ich habe eine offizielle
geburtstagsparty warum sind die denn
schon da war ich beim kochen
ich brauche musik ich habe kein geld für
musik muss sagen verkaufen ich meine wir
sind jetzt vorbereitet wird der brauch
kein bett mehr
dafür brauchen wir musik na ja wir
können jetzt auf jeden fall so musikbox
leisten kommt man sie ja da habe ich das
für das bett verkauft haben können wir
jetzt einen traurigen cd-player dahin
bestellen eigentlich müsse man das
draußen in platzieren
essen ist jetzt gemacht wisst ihr was
jetzt müssen wir anfangen die party mal
zum gang zu bringen
[Musik]
meine gäste feiern
bild autonews single singt hört auf zu
kochen
danke aufzukommen
das ist der partie ich hab doch
testessen und hier
ich habe es geschafft schwimmen mit
allen bittens leute wir gehen
[Musik]
und jetzt wird die pool-party niemals
aufhören
man kann einfach raus betrug ärgert
nicht geht nicht gehen ohne leute ist es
ist 23 uhr bleibt hier
okay das passiert wenn ihr in euren pool
die leiter raus nehmt eure gäste
verschwinden einfach es tut mir leid
wenn es ach du hast es super gemacht
schau dir dieses festessen anja leute
ich habe es geschafft die perfekte party
zu veranstalten es macht mir viel spaß
ich weiß nicht wie lange ich jetzt schon
so saß falls sie mal lust hat das
auszuprobieren und eine beschreibung
gibt es einen link da könnt ihr zwei
tage lang sims ausprobieren und
natürlich könnt ihr euch auch das
erweiterungspack das erweiterungspack
jahreszeiten ich hoffe euch jetzt
zuschauen spaß gemacht ich bin wieder
mächtig geworden ich habe das früher
halt immer so viel gespielt und jetzt
unterricht da wieder strudeln drin also
leute bis dann ich jetzt einen pool
party veranstalten